Who do I turn to when I need saving
Cuz you move mountains
I can't do the same
And did you think bout that
when you left us
I know it's selfish
But I can't help it
If I fall down tomorrow
And there's no one to blame
Water under the bridge
Let it burn like a flame
You're not here and it kills me
I'm not numb to the pain
Now there's blood on my hands
Guess we're one in the same
Imagine if I needed
some advice you never give
Imagine if I end up
on the path you never laid
They say you're here in spirit
like I'm meant to let it fade
Life gave me lemons
I can't make it lemonade
Blood on my hands
but for you it's an affair
I would've went myself
if you never lead the way
I would've held your hand
if you needed me to pray
Hindsight's a...
I can't look her in the face
Pain in my heart but I put it in the grave
Pain in my soul but I put it in the grave
Nowhere else to put it
that's the way that I was raised
Would've took a bullet
if it meant you could've stayed
It's like they overcharging
the price that I paid
Left it, left it, broke
that's why I charged to the game
As long as I'm alive
I'll be carrying your name
They'll never cut you out the frame, but
Who do I turn to
When I need saving
Cuz you move mountains
I can't do the same
And did you think bout that
When you left us
I know it's selfish
But I can't help it
If I fall down tomorrow
And there's no one to blame
Water under the bridge
Let it burn like a flame
You're not here and it kills me
I'm not numb to the pain
Now there's blood on my hands
Guess we're one in the same